[Music]
we were the best of friends even closer
than then people could have imagined
it's really hard because he did it
because he had no choice and it's just a
giant giant loss Bob Saget unable to
hide the emotion join legendary comics
like Brad Garrett Kevin Nealon and one
of Robins dearest friends Billy Crystal
to premiere the new HBO documentary
Robin Williams come inside my mind when
I was 18 and a half and I had to follow
him on an open mic night and I think
that's what started with 20 years of
drinking the film is told through both
Robins own words and by those closest in
his life including his 35 year old son
Zach he was the most successful person
they know and yet he didn't always feel
that during our first et interview with
the Mork & Mindy star in 1982 it was
clear just how much Robin relied on his
inner circle it's good friends
by having good friends at eyes you can
get through anything you know we spent
so much time with you and Robin over the
years
what was it like trying to do an
interview with him well we we had a
great rapport we didn't know where was
gonna go but I was at he always looked
to me to bring him back to earth it was
a privilege to trade blows with him bye
bye say something we entire I'm just all
tapped out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]